bienvenue dans la famille malaucène
ça commence chez les mâles fief du
personnel alors moi j'arrive devant lyon
la lehman qui très sérieux toujours axé
petites lunettes et une cliente cas pas
l'air très content pour carboniser tout
le repas de noël seul art ans a survécu
poutre au boulot ça consiste en quoi
exactement
je suis là pour me faire engueuler bravo
ficelé vous ont pas été pour les fêtes
et vous descendrez tendu jusqu'à ce que
les clients qui posait problème en ans a
porté plainte
c'est peut-être pas la peine d'aller si
loin oui mais non et si moi je suis bouc
émissaire ok mis sur les tons langage je
parle pas comme ton far west gourdasse
on a tout le temps que tu surveilles ton
langage jérémy tu parles d'un capteur on
se fou j'avais des manches et outil
qu'est ce qui dit
vous êtes au delà de mes espérances un
vrai bouquet de compétition ce boulot
n'est pas digne de toi je me retrouve
béquille de la famille et à ma mère qui
va faire des enfants aux quatre coins du
monde elle revient poudre à belleville
et qui s'occupe de tout après brad et
moi c'est quoi quand même dans sa
famille au fait un curieux métier qui
attire nécessairement les coûts toda
je suis journaliste on préférait pas
contre connaissance je suis très douée
pour réchauffer les pieds est ce que
j'ai l'air d'une fille comme ça
quand vous aurez fini avec votre
séquence émotion je pourrais vous
montrer ma bombe quoi tu as construit
une bombe
vous êtes notre principal suspect je
veux malaucène à la plupart du temps
dans la dune arrière des sons que dans
ce matin à merde non non non j'ai tout
compris vous allez faire quoi une fois
viré je te vois évidemment à l'eau
fraîche préparée l'eau fraîche
je m'occupe du reste
j'ai eu beaucoup de choses horribles au
cours de ma carrière mais votre pyjama
tient le haut du pavé